What if you could use your nose
to snorkel, or uproot a small tree,
or smell water from several miles away?
Well, elephants wouldn't
be that impressed.
They do it on the daily,
thanks to what's inside their trunk.
If you were to dissect an elephant trunk,
it would actually look more like
the inside of your tongue than your nose.
Trunks, tongues, and even octopus arms
are unique organs called
muscular hydrostats.
That means they're made
almost entirely of muscle,
and an elephant's trunk has a lot of them,
about 40,000, compared
to around 650 muscles
in the entire human body.
Normally, muscles depend
on bones and joints
to move and exert force.
When we pick up a dumbbell, for example,
our bicep pulls on our forearm bones
and that causes them to swing up
around our elbow joint.
But in an elephant trunk,
there are no bones to pull
and no joints to hinge on.
The muscles take on that role instead.
This makes trunks incredibly flexible
so they can move in all directions.
And all those muscles mean
they're powerful enough
to lift hundreds of pounds,
yet delicate enough to
pick up a tortilla chip
without even cracking it.
But while trunks may be
structured like a tongue
and function like an arm,
they are, in fact, a nose,
and an exceptional one.
An animal's sense of smell is linked
to the number of olfactory
receptor genes it has.
And elephants, well,
they have a lot of them,
nearly 2,000 - more than
any other animal we know of.
Bloodhounds, for example,
only have about 800
while humans have even fewer.
In fact, an elephant's nose is so good
it can actually sniff out bombs.
People have reported
that African elephants
avoid land mines in Angola
and in 2015, researchers
put it to the test.
Elephants were presented
with a lineup of buckets
filled with different
smells, including TNT,
the main ingredient in land mines.
Out of 97 TNT samples,
elephants detected all but one.
Of course, their trunks didn't
evolve as bomb detectors.
They use their nose like we use our eyes,
to find food and water,
to avoid predators,
and to map out other elephants nearby.
That's like walking into a family reunion
with your eyes closed and knowing
exactly where everyone is.
But if you can believe it,
there are even more tricks
up their, trunks.
When elephants traverse
deep rivers, for example,
they curve their trunk into a snorkel,
and when bathing, they
can use it as a hose,
or more like a fire hose.
With one suck, a trunk can pull in
as much as 10 liters of water.
And the trunk's impressive
abilities haven't gone unnoticed.
In fact, if you stick a mirror
in front of an elephant,
one of their favorite activities
is to open their mouth and
check out their trunks.
Let's admit it, if you
had a nose like that,
you would do the exact same thing.